absolutely not that's one of those  things he's gonna have to experience for  himself i can't go over there nobody's  gonna hold his hand i'm sure there's  gonna be some  personal attacks there's gonna be some  um  you know something that might you know  some words that may trigger you as  personally but that's just how fans are  they want to get into our skin they want  to  you know  let their voices be heard you know i  think  part of the experience of coming to an  nba game is the heck you know some  people don't even enjoy basketball they  just like  their lives are so  they they get to just aim it at other  people you know so it's easy to kind of  get that release at a basketball game so  ben understands that and i'm sure some  stuff may be funny yeah you never know  but at the end of the day we realized  that life is amazing we play the game in  basketball for a litter  and  a little bit of trash talk is what it is